[Musique]
la dispute a débuté sur les réseaux
sociaux
la soeur de la victime aurait reproché
aux suspects via un groupe snapshot
d'avoir mal parlé à d'autres filles de
ce même groupe
vendredi le suspect de 14 ans se dispute
avec marjorie va chercher un couteau de
cuisine puis poignardé la jeune fille de
17 ans au niveau du thorax
ce n'est pas normal que des parents
laissent traîner leurs enfants dans les
cités ce n'est pas normal que des
enfants sont sains mais au jour
d'aujourd'hui qu'un enfant vienne tuer
un autre afin nous sommes entrés dans
l'âge d'internet maintenant depuis de
nombreuses années et il n'y a pas eu
l'évolution des moeurs qui doit aller
avec l'évolution technologique
autrement dit ce qui se passait beaucoup
trop sauvage des ça doit changer c'est
ce que nous commençons à faire casser la
spirale de la violence et en finir avec
l'impunité des délinquants notamment les
mineurs voilà ce que souhaite xavier
bertrand candidat à la présidentielle de
instaurer la majorité pénale à 15 ans
j'ai connu des jeunes tourquennois qui
arrêté à 16 ans ont eu à 22 ans
seulement la peine du fait qu'ils
avaient commis lorsqu'il avait 16 ans
comment voulez vous que cette justice
fonctionne et la réforme de l'ordonance
des mineurs voulue par le garde des
sceaux qui permet notamment une réponse
pénale en moins de six mois sera une
plus grande efficacité me semble utile
de mettre des adolescents en prison
sanofi annonce de très bons résultats de
son vaccin candidat avec 95 %
d'efficacité
effectivement cette fois-ci valable sur
toutes les tranches d'âge c'était
quelque chose de très important pour
nous on voulait avoir une efficacité qui
soit très élevé dans toutes les tranches
d'âge c'est le cas avec ces résultats le
vaccin qui se conserve dans un simple
réfrigérateur pourrait être également un
bon vaccin de rappel selon le
laboratoire pharmaceutique le variant
sud africain sera à l'étude lors de la
troisième phase le lancement de la
production serait imminent plus de temps
à perdre pour sanofi qui devra toutefois
attendre la fin de l'année pour une
éventuelle mise sur le marché
attendez les gars j'arrive quand notre
dessinateur estiment que le virus aura
déjà été terrassé par les géants moderna
pfizer esprit c'est une préconisation
pour assurer l'avenir démographique
selon françois bayrou la france doit
faire plus d'enfants
ou alors elle doit accueillir des
personnes d'autres pays
selon lui il manque 40 à 50 mille
naissances chaque année pourra
assurer le renouvellement des
générations et le pen ruinera touche là
en une élection
regardez son projet lepeu du projet
qu'elle a dévoilée en matière économique
elle nous dit je vais donner cent mille
euros à chaque premier enfant ce sera
d'abord un prêt et ensuite un don à
partir du troisième enfant et 750 points
d'essence par an 75 milliards sur la
table
ensuite elle et trouve ou affaire a fait
la une du jdd dimanche l' enquête qui
accuse le pen l'enquète ce n'est pas
celle du journal mais un rapport de
police qui a fuité 17 personnes mises en
cause dont marine le pen
près de 7 millions d'euros violation du
secret de la structure secrète le tout
et violé la secret de l'enquète secret
de l'instruction
ce qui me gêne c'est que dans ce qui a
été publiée hier dans le journal du
dimanche
il ya peut-être qu'une partie des
éléments moi je vais pas me prononcer
sur une partie des éléments
ça fait maintenant cinq ans cinq ans que
ce dossier est à l'instruction cinq ans
qu on nous ressort cette affaire à
chaque fois à un mois des élections et
je le rappelle à votre corporation
les journalistes sont pas des juges ou
des procureurs ou s'ils veulent le
devenir qui passe l'école nationale de
la magistrature et pour le devenir et la
montre la montre de dupont cesser ses
boutons de manchette
moi je suis qu'est ce que c'est la
manchette et une montre qui est cher
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de dire
on est là c'est la journée
internationale de lutte contre
l'homophobie
à cette occasion une nouvelle campagne
est lancée par santé publique france
avec un clip dont le slogan est je fais
la différence
il ya la violence physique qu'on voit
mais aussi celles plus silencieuse
causés par les discriminations avec
cette campagne de santé publique france
des chiffres chocs